hey everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by thrive
market and we are back with another
episode of turning your fear foods into
hunger crushing combos but first let me
drop in here to tell you about my
sponsor thrive market so thrive market
is an online membership based market
that aims to make health-focused
specialty products more affordable and
accessible to everyone basically you do
a guided shopping quiz to get a
personalized shopping list and product
recommendations specifically tailored to
your diet goals and household needs you
can also filter by different diet goals
like vegan or fair trade and shop for
your essential groceries beauty
supplements home goods and more they
work directly with every brand so you
get the best prices and if you find a
better price somewhere else they'll
match it i also love that they deliver
everything in carbon neutral packaging
from zero waste warehouses and shipping
is free on orders over 49
currently they only deliver to the
contiguous u.s so i always order as soon
as i go down to florida but they have
one month and 12 month options so you
can choose the membership model that
best fits your lifestyle the 12-month
membership is a really great deal
because it does come down to just five
dollars a month and if you join today
you'll get 40 off of your first order
and a free gift so definitely check out
my link in the description to sign up
nostalgic childhood edition now very
quickly you can check out my disclaimer
on screen or in the description below
but i also want to remind everyone that
this series is not about never having
your fear foods all on their own without
any fiber protein or healthy fats
nothing bad is going to happen if you
just want to enjoy them as they are
without all the balancing accoutrements
but for those of you who are having
trouble incorporating some of these fear
foods into your diet these foods are
just foods they're morally neutral foods
and i want to show all of you guys at
home how you can incorporate them into
your daily diet into balanced meals and
snacks that not only are going to leave
you satisfied because they're tasty but
are also going to keep you satiated as
well so on that note let's make some
hunger crushing combos
okay so first things first pop-tarts is
there anything in this world more
nostalgic than a pop-tart with like the
sugary frosting and the sprinkles on top
and like the semi-dry stale tasting
pastry with the jam inside i mean i'm
really hoping they're as good as i
remember so i will say and you guys
leave me in the comment section below my
sister and i would always have this like
battle where she was team pop tarts and
i was team pillsbury strudel kind of
toaster strudel things is that what
they're called anyways i feel like the
pastry was just way better it's soft
it's kind of like flaky like a croissant
not stale like this but i do feel that
this has more of a nostalgic element so
we went with the pop tarts today and i'm
gonna show you how to turn these into
hunger crushing combos but first let's
pop some tarts
okay check it out we've got some
delicious thick full fat greek yogurt
and just the plain stuff or you could
use flavored of course so a quick
reminder for all you folks at home the
hunger crushing combo is protein fiber
and healthy fats so for this combination
we have some full fat greek yogurt which
is packed with protein you could use
flavored if you want but this is just
plain because we got lots of flavor
going in
i've got some beautiful berries here so
ripe so delish pop lots of those bad
boys in
that's gonna be our fiber and we've got
some healthy fats we've got a little
mixed nut situation here brazil nuts
almonds cashews and pecans so
that
is our healthy fat
now the moment of truth do you remember
that warm pop-tart feeling in your hand
because i am being brought back to my
childhood this was my breakfast pretty
much every day of the week so what we're
going to do oh remember this
guys
[Music]
just as i remembered them slightly stale
very sweet that little layer of icing
it just hits different so of course if
you want to have a balanced breakfast
you have your pop-tarts you have your
bowl of kind of yogurt fruit and nuts
it's a great little parfait or you do
what i like to do and you break this bad
boy up you mix it in there you get
little bits of frosting you get little
bits of jam
it's warm it's flaky guys
it's a beautiful thing
how fun
is that
guys this bowl
just hits different and i find that the
sweetness from the jam just like gets
into all the little the little spoonfuls
of yogurt so it really does flavor it so
much my mouth is watering just thinking
about it because it's so good i gotta
get a little piece of that crust in
there oh yeah jam
genius guys i'm doing this every day
moms and dads at home this is a winner
your kids are gonna freak out
all right
number two is
kd
well we call it kd in canada i guess in
the states it's called craft macaroni
and cheese dinner we call it katie like
craft dinner so the packaging's a little
bit different but the nostalgia is still
the same
so i have a funny story about katie or
craft dinner when we were growing up my
mom
really
like really does not like cheese what
and she doesn't even like the smell of
cheese so we weren't allowed to have
craft dinner when i was a kid in the
house at least it wasn't a health
problem it wasn't about it being
unhealthy or junk or whatever that was
not the issue the issue was just that it
really does smell very cheesy and my mom
didn't want it stinking up the house so
basically anytime i'd go to anyone's
house like a friend's house grandma's
house etc my sister and i would
basically beg for kd
so we've had a lot of time to make up
for our kd
deprivation as children and let's just
say i keep my pantry stocked so i
already had my katie in the pantry and i
actually often beef it up into a more
substantial meal for myself and for the
kids so that's what we're gonna do today
the kids are out they're playing they
are going to be so excited when they
come home and there is kd or kraft
dinner or whatever you want to call it
for lunch let's do it okay step one is
to just cook the mac and cheese as it
says on the package so you boil the
water add the pasta drain it put a
little bit of butter in there and a
little bit of milk and then we make it a
hunger crushing combo
already messed up
over boiled the water
whoops
add your butter
yeah a little milk
you add the happy powder
and we give it a little stir
now we turn it into a hunger crushing
combo and oh my god this smells like my
childhood step one we add some fiber
i've got some frozen cauliflower and
broccoli here
i'm gonna add some
cottage cheese here
this is going to add a ton of protein
now we've got some shredded cheese just
to get in there with a little more
cheese action some healthy fats
and then i've got some nutritional yeast
here that's going to bump up the protein
and add a little bit more fiber as well
[Music]
all right look
at
that
get a little broccoli in there
it is so much better than just the box
stuff on its own and it really didn't
take that much more effort so let's
recap we've got tons of protein in here
from the cottage cheese and the milk and
the extra cheese that i put in there
plus the nutritional yeast which by the
way if you haven't tried nutritional
yeast it actually tastes like cheese so
it's a great add-in for any cheesy dish
that you make we've also got lots of
fats from the cheese and i used a full
fat cottage cheese and we got the full
fat milk in there plus we've got lots of
fiber going on from our veg and a little
bit from the nutritional yeast as well
it is a serious upgrade and i know my
kids are gonna be excited now the big
question is are you team ketchup on your
kd or no ketchup i am all for the
ketchup but i'm gonna enjoy it just for
all of its cheesy glory that out
it's gonna be a good day now this next
nostalgic childhood food is near and
dear to my heart because it pretty much
like sustained me through childhood and
that is the combination of grilled
cheese and tomato soup so good so
classic you know you don't want to mess
with it but nowadays i actually make
grilled cheese all the time and i also
just love a good canned tomato soup you
just can't make it from scratch and have
it taste the same so we are going to
hunger crush and combo it but first i
want to do a little story time because
my mom always tells me this story about
when i was a kid um she made me grilled
cheese one time and kids are funny
they're fickle some days like all they
want to do is have grilled cheese and
the next day they are complaining about
said grilled cheese and i was just
having a day apparently and you know how
grilled cheese as like all toast gets
like brown when you cook it well i
thought that was dirt and i had my mom
wash the grilled cheese i had a full-on
tantrum because the grilled cheese
looked dirty to me and it needed to be
washed let's get weird let's get weird
so what did i get i got soggy grilled
cheese now we are not going to make sake
grilled cheese today but we are going to
make a more satiating grilled cheese and
i'm going to show you how we do it okay
so real talk here folks i
am not going gonna make grilled cheese
with like a really hearty whole grain
toast i'm just not i love whole grain
toast i love a good sea bread for like
my nut butter breakfast toast or for
sandwiches but grilled cheese you gotta
stick with the og now i prefer sourdough
toast like i just straight up prefer
this is not diet culture this is not
wellness culture i just like sourdough
bread so i'm having sourdough bread for
my grilled cheese um you could also use
a white bread but i just find that this
stands up better to you know the soft
inside and the crunchy outside that you
want to achieve with a really good gc so
that's what we're using to make it i
always does anyone else like butter the
wrong side i mean it doesn't matter more
butter more flavor but i'm going to show
you guys a really great little hack that
i learned just to get more even
consistency on the bread we melt
la butter oh we we really vouched
all right let's make a little room for
the love so let's see
out out in in where do we begin in i've
melted my butter using a little brush
here
i'm gonna get a nice even coat
all over
the butter is where the love is so
we wanna be like a little more generous
beauty all right
all right open that bad boy up now
here's what we're gonna do folks
first things first i'm gonna release
oh my goodness
i might just have to omit this part from
the recipe
oh thank goodness all right
all is right in the world we're gonna
add a little beautiful pesto onto one
side of le bread and this is gonna add
some delicious healthy fats because
we've got nuts in here and we've got
some extra virgin olive oil and you can
make it from scratch but mama don't have
time for that
hello it's gonna add flavor beaut
smells so fresh and so delicious
yes all right
now the next question is what do we
layer first but i think what i'm going
to do is i'm going to do
some cheese down first
the cheese layer protects the bread from
the tomato juice tomatoes
it's just a tight squeeze that's what
she said that's my joke all right we're
going to add a little fiber here we're
going to add some more fiber with some
greens
and we've got
some chicken
for some protein this is just leftover
chicken so whatever i had in the fridge
this could be any kind of protein that
you have or like it could be tofu it
could be um ground meats
whatever oh yeah all right anything else
anything else friends okay do we want to
do a double layer of cheese
we do you convince me um more cheese
more cheese more cheese please hercules
always a good time okay i think we're
good to go plop it on there oh
she thick oh we lost piece of chicken
now we cook it okay gc hack i do a
little bit of olive oil in the pan which
not only adds some healthy fats but also
prevents the butter from burning
let me let that heat up
oh
hello oh
she just keeps escaping out the back end
put that baby to rest
while she cooks we make tomato soup
only the classic obviously
now to bump up the fiber and protein
even more i'm going to add a ton of
nutritional yeast to the soup that also
is going to add a little cheesy flavor
and it's just super delicious and
nutritious
look at that
oh my goodness see i would have made my
mom wash this but it's perfection need a
little more olive oil here
now
we press
now if you want to get that cheese
melted you gotta
put the lid on
oh
it's like perfection that's how i like
it
so good okay let's recap this beauty so
we oh she's hot so we've got we've got a
fair bit of fiber in the sourdough bread
plus we've got more fiber in the veggies
that we added we've got protein in our
chicken we've got some fat in the cheese
and in the oil that we're cooking in as
well as the pesto over here we've got oh
she's hot she's so hot two-hander
we have a little extra fiber and protein
in the soup thanks to the um nutritional
yeast and tons of flavor i mean you just
you can't duplicate the goodness of
canned soup but you know what we need to
do i'll tell you what we need to do we
need to dip when i dip you dip we dip it
i can't i can't pick it up you're just
gonna have to believe me perfection just
perfection cheesy goodness perfection
it's grilled cheese grown up if you know
what i'm saying
okay so another
favorite breakfast of mine growing up
and apparently a lot of yours as well
when i pulled you guys on my community
page was cinnamon sugar toast i have so
many memories of just wanting cinnamon
sugar toast for breakfast or for a
bedtime snack and i feel like the
cinnamon flavor is inherently comforting
but when you get the sugar in there and
like the buttery toast and the crunch of
a nicely toasted piece of white bread
so a lot of you wanted to know how to
turn that into a hunger crushing combo
and the first thing i thought was i'm
not going to change the cinnamon sugar
toast when i was growing up you used to
be able to buy like cinnamon sugar
butter i don't know if that still exists
anymore but i figured we can also just
make our own with cinnamon sugar and
butter so that's what we're gonna do and
i'm going to pair it with a savory piece
of toast to give you those hunger
crushing compounds let's do it
okay so on our first piece of toast
we're just going to do
a classic
kind of
butter with cinnamon sugar situation
right to the edge
then i've got some just like basic sugar
loads of cinnamon basically equal parts
but that's a
preference give it a stir
[Applause]
it smells so good
cake it on there
yes yes
yes and the heat from the toast and the
melted butter just like oh this looks
like my childhood
rub it in there rub a dub dub
hello
that's the stuff
right there baby yeah baby yeah
now we do like a savory accompaniment to
our cinnamon toast so we've got avocado
and she is a beaut hello that's going
down
that is our healthy fats gonna mash
[Music]
so here i've got some drained and rinsed
white beans that is our protein that's
some more fiber
and there's also lots of fiber in
avocado as well so this is my little
hack here a little lemon juice
for flavor and i'm gonna season it
heavily with you know what
so give me a
minute all right
let's load
this protein avocado smash onto our
sourdough which also has some fiber
hitting lots of boxes here
folks in a insanely delicious meal whoa
i like it
thick
and high you know what they say the
higher the avocado toast the closer to
god so
we're just gonna load her up there and a
little sprinkle of
you know
everyone's favorite
bagel spice
oh my gosh and i cannot forget hemp
hearts so
a little more healthy fats fiber and
protein in there oh she good sweet
savory we get all the things in this
let's recap folks we have
fiber in the bread fiber in the avocado
fiber in the hem parts fiber in the
white beans we've got protein in our
white beans plus our hemp hearts and
loads of healthy fats in the hemp hearts
and in the avocado not to mention this
is taking all our boxes right we've got
our sweet breakfast and our savory and
we can alternate or we can do one after
the other or vice versa there's no rules
here in the hunger crushing combo world
it only has to taste good so let's do it
yum double young i don't even know which
one i want more the good news is i'mma
eat this all so let me do that well
folks i hope that bring back as many
delicious nostalgic childhood food
memories for you guys as it did for me
honestly all of these were my favorite
foods and it just brought me back to a
simpler time in life but also now i have
such great ideas to like feed my family
and myself on the regular and thank you
again to thrive market for sponsoring
don't forget to check out my link below
to get 40 off of your first order and a
free gift if you like this video be sure
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on other fear foods that
you guys want to see me turn into hunger
crushing combos subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]